well active learning is the idea that
students to really learn something to
really understand something have to be
actively involved and that just sitting
passively and listening to a lecture
really doesn't help students develop the
higher order cognitive processes that
they need to really really understand
something so you can listen to something
you can watch a movie you can watch TV
and you can generally get the plot but
if you're asked to to recall specific
details or to to even explain a
particular nuance associated with the TV
show or movie you can't really do it and
that's what happens often in the lecture
is that students will sit in the lecture
though write down what's being said but
they're not really engaged with the
material so active learning is this idea
of people say minds on always hands-on
sometimes those students have to to be
actively with their mind thinking about
the material applying what's being said
and given opportunities within the
lecture to apply what's being taught or
what's being the topic at hand and then
active learning
strictly speaking means that you just
you're just one a particular individual
is active interactive we tend to parse
that a little bit and say interactive
learning would mean the student has been
active in his or her own mind in
thinking about the material but then is
also interacting with others peers or
potentially the faculty member or TA in
order to to further develop
understanding construct meaning for for
the topic I always start maybe the
second session of the class the second
class meeting is a discussion of what we
know about how people learn so a
discussion of the literature and the
research on human cognition and learning
and and if you take a constructivist
point of view or constructionist point
of view which really says that as I said
before to understand people have to make
meaning of a topic they have to
construct their own meaning and we show
the research that really shows that this
is true for a higher level
of processes people have to be actively
engaged and there's research to show
that we also show the classroom based
research so Freeman's 2014 paper that
was a meta-analysis of 225 other studies
that showed that in courses in
college-level courses with we're active
learning was used there was a 12%
decrease in the failure rate and they
normalized it to all of the important
factors that they should be normalized
to the experience of the instructor the
size of the class the type of the
institution the the situation the way
the position that the class is situated
within the larger curriculum and and
across the board it was shown that there
was a 12% decrease on average of the
failure rate and they make a comment in
the paper that if that had been a
clinical trial of a drug and 12% of the
people on the drug head showed marked
improvement they would have had to stop
the trial and and give everyone the drug
so this idea that there's a 12% decrease
in the failure rate in courses that use
active learning to me is pretty
compelling that we should all be using
active learning so whenever possible
because we have an MIT our students our
MIT students we use data we use the
research and we we try to find really
good research solid research that shows
the the way people learn and then how to
support that with specific Act classroom
practices so many of the students
haven't had the experience of being in a
class where active learning was used so
they don't really understand it so when
we start to talk about it as a way of
teaching they may not really get it so
throughout the course from the first the
first class all the way through we I try
to use several different types of active
learning exercises each class so the
students themselves are actively engaged
with the material from the first day so
I may have them break into pairs and
discuss a particular topic or identify
something they didn't they didn't
understand from the pre class readings
and then after three minutes week they
can either share their comments with
someone else or maybe we just report out
to the larger group that that if they
just report if they just write down and
then report back that's a pretty good
example of active learning it's a pretty
simple it's what what you might call
low-hanging fruit in terms of what it
would take what it takes for a faculty
member to do that so I'll do that I'll
have them do that and then I step back
and say okay why did I ask you to think
about it why did I ask you to take three
minutes before we had this discussion so
I try to deconstruct the exercise for
them showing them the advantages for the
learner